good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm lawrence jones and it has
now been a full week since the democrats
got beat down in virginia where glen
younkin led a red wave across the state
and the dems that have plenty of time to
reflect on what happened plenty of time
to come up with a plan so they don't
humiliate themselves again in the
midterms perhaps they should tweak their
message or god forbid move a little
toward the center it's obvious that
critical race theory is a feeling and a
failing economy aren't a winning
platform so what did the democrats
settle on are they going to turn down
the crazy
quite the contrary today we learned they
decided to go all in
as president said president biden has
said
america is back
so that's the message you're going to go
with america is back everything is
awesome you better believe it
kamala and i were sent here by the
american people to deliver
and that's what we've done
so when you watch that you're saying to
yourself what world are they living in
what's really disturbing is they think
this whole strategy that everything is
awesome is the answer to joe's biden's
plunging popularity numbers neat proof
look no further than the white house
briefing room where all week they've
been carting out different cabinet
secretaries to explain just how awesome
infrastructure is now obviously nobody
cares about this but that won't stop
them from trying
did it ever cross their mind that
perhaps the president's plunging poll
numbers have nothing to do with
infrastructure
that they might have something to do
with vaccine mandates the embarrassment
in afghanistan or the out of control
inflation
that is so bad that people may not be
able to afford thanksgiving dinner nope
that can't possibly be wrong
about any of those things everything is
so awesome
it's you who needs to be reprogrammed to
believe the new line it's simple
everything is awesome spread the word
now biden's communication department the
mainstream media already is have you
seen some of the garbage they're pumping
out
here's a tweet from msnbc and this is a
quote
inflation is actually a good thing right
see everything is awesome it's almost
like the dem stole this entire strategy
from the lego movie where conformity is
key
and no matter how bad it seems
[Music]
drink overpriced coffee there you go
that's 37
wow awesome
instructions coming in from central
okay it says
[Music]
[Applause]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else